[Music]
life is like riding a bicycle to keep
your balance you must keep moving
[Music]
the important thing is to not stop
questioning curiosity has its own reason
for existing
[Music]
i believe in one thing that only a life
lived for others as a life worth living
where the world ceases to be the scene
of our personal hopes and wishes where
we face it as free beings admiring
asking observing there we enter the
realm of art and science
although i am a typical loner in daily
life my consciousness of belonging to
the invisible community of those who
strive for truth beauty and justice has
preserved me from feeling isolated
look deep into nature and then you will
understand everything better
all religions arts and sciences are
branches of the same tree
[Music]
a table a chair a bowl of fruit and a
violin
what else does a man need to be happy
learn from yesterday live for today hope
for tomorrow the important thing is not
to stop questioning
he who can no longer pause to wonder and
stand wrapped in awe is as good as dead
his eyes are closed
a happy man is too satisfied with the
present to dwell too much on the future
strive not to be a success but rather to
be of value
i speak to everyone in the same way
whether he is the garbage man or the
president of the university
imagination is more important than
knowledge knowledge is limited
imagination encircles the world
we cannot solve our problems with the
same thinking we used when we created
them
[Music]
i am enough of an artist to draw freely
upon my imagination
imagination is more important than
knowledge knowledge is limited
imagination encircles the world
the most beautiful experience we can
have as the mysterious
a question that sometimes drives me hazy
am i or are the others crazy
[Music]
the important thing is not to stop
questioning curiosity has its own reason
for existence
try not to become a man of success but
rather try to become a man of value
the greatest scientists are artists as
well
science can flourish only in an
atmosphere of free speech
[Music]
it occurred to me by intuition and music
was the driving force behind that
intuition
my discovery was the result of musical
perception
[Music]
i would teach peace rather than war i
would inculcate love rather than hate
[Music]
i have no special talent i am only
passionately curious
[Music]
if i were not a physicist i would
probably be a musician
i often think in music i live my
daydreams in music i see my life in
terms of music i cannot tell if i would
have done any creative work of
importance in music but i do know that i
get most joy in life out of my violin
[Music]
i believe in intuitions and inspirations
i sometimes feel that i am right i do
not know that i am
my passion for social justice has often
brought me into conflict with people as
has my aversion to any obligation
independence i did not regard as
absolutely necessary
[Music]
a person who never made a mistake never
tried anything new
few are those who see with their own
eyes and feel with their own hearts
i believe in standardizing automobiles i
do not believe in standardizing human
beings
[Music]
a man should look for what is and not
for what he thinks should be
i am by heritage a jew by citizenship a
swiss and by make up a human being and
only a human being without any special
attachment to any state or national
entity whatsoever
[Music]
great spirits have always encountered
violent opposition from mediocre minds
for watching subscribe to the wisdom of
the ages channel